du hast wahrscheinlich auf dieses Video
geklickt und hast dir gedacht das kann
gar nicht wahr sein und ich hätte es
auch niemals für möglich gehalten aber
ich habe Gordon Ramsey getroffen und
zwar hat Gordon vor seinem Restaurant
Hells kitchen in Las Vegas eine tv-sh
produziert Beil der er selbst persönlich
anwesend war ab diesem Zeitpunkt war mir
klar ich will ihn irgendwie eine Frage
stellen damit ich daraus ein cooles real
oder tiktok oder irgendwas machen kann
und habe mir gedacht ich frage ihn
welches sein persönliches
Lieblingsrestaurant ist nach langem
Warten hat sich dann irgendwann der
richtige Moment ergeben und was dann
passiert ist hätte ich selbst nicht
gedacht aber se
selbst ti out of in Vegas one is best go
today
I okay
okay
eam oh
wow es ist jetzt gerade ein paar Tage
später ich kann das aber immer noch
nicht wirklich glauben was war das bitte
für ein Zufall und wie nett war er auch
aber das sollte es ja noch nicht gewesen
sein denn wir hatten eine Mission und
die war ganz klar drei verschiedene gen
ramsy Restaurants besuchen und
herausfinden ob wir auch wirklich
eingeladen sind weil Gord hat das ja
einfach so daher gesagt wir mussen
herausfinden ob es stimmt deshalb ab zum
ersten Restaurant was ma wir jetzt
Burger essen würde ich sagen oder wir
machen das was Papa Gordon uns gesagt
hat Ramy Burger ihr erinnert euch wir
hab me London eingegessen der war
wirklich nicht gut und ich bin gespannt
ob die in Las Vegas hier ein bisschen
besser sind aber am Ende des Tages in
Geschenken schaut man nicht ins Maul ne
bezahlt ja ja hoffentlich ich hoffe ich
bin echt gespannt wenn wir das den
Leuten zeigen was sie dazu sagen denkst
du er wird bezahlen oder nicht ich glaub
nicht das ist nur ein bisschen Laberei
gewesen der kann sich eh nicht mehr an
uns erinnern steht schon gen Ramsey
Burger da bin ich am allermeisten
gespannt ob wir wirklich bezahlen müssen
oder nicht das krasse ist Las Vegas
gehört Gordon Ramsey ich habe ihn ja
gefragt von den ganzen Restaurants hier
zu welchen sollen wir gehen er hat zehn
oder so er hat zehn Restaurants einfach
in Las Vegas ich glaube wirklich dass er
hier fast schon noch größer ist als in
UK selber also in London hat er auf
jeden Fall noch mal mehr Restaurants
aber Bro das ist das andere Ende der
Welt Ramsey Burger is wow Alter mit dem
Feuer da vorne ist ja crazy jetzt bin
ich gespannt jetzt müssen wir ein
Ansprechpartner finden und dem unsere
Story erzählen
hast du sowas schon mal gesehen in
Deutschland wä das so nein sagt nein
überen jetzt davon wirsst
kriegen ich glaub der macht
das Perf thank you
was für einer Simulation leben wir weiß
du was hier ein Burger
kostet
3399 für uns dan got danke Gott wir
nehmen den4 hour Burger mit
wahrscheinlich mit short das dann 24
Stunden gegart wurde und
den Ultimate Cheeseburger so als
SP Kiner Snack zwisendurch warten wir
ab Freunde 20 Cocktails umsonst
schmecken noch besonders
gut go so sieht also ein 34 Burger aus
bzw in unserem Fall ein 0 Burger guckt
euch erstm an diese Barbecue Soße das
Paty zwei verschiedene slies Käse
dazwischen haben wir noch ein paar Pilze
oder ist das das shortrip short shortrip
Bacon so ein laugiges weiches Bang und
er ist so hoch dass diese stecknad schon
fast verschwindet die uns verrätt das
ist ein Gordon ramseyg dann haben wir
noch den altim mit Cheeseburger er hat
unten keine Soße ein dickes Petty Käse
und oben keine Soße in welcher Welt
macht das Sinn welcher Welt ist das der
alte mit Cheeseburger soll ich einfach
mal probieren probier einfach
mal ich muss sagen dafür dass da so
wenig drauf ist ist echt saftig und
schmeckt verdammt gut unter dem Käse
haben sie die Soße versteckt der ist auf
jeden Fall schon mal sehr nice ich glaub
davon kriegt man wirklich einfach so
eine Maulsperre wow also es ist einfach
ein geiler Burger er ist gigantisch groß
kriegst halt gefühlt so die Substanz von
fünf Big Macs ich weiß gar nicht wie ich
das in meinen Mund bekommen soll
Alter so we can just leave
now Perf bye bye ja ne also so spart man
Geld wenn man in Vegas ist wir sind
gerade eigentlich auf dem Weg zu einem
anderen Restaurant von Gorden aber ihr
seht vielleicht im Hintergrund da ist
schon wieder eins diesem Mann gehört
einfach Las Vegas gefühlt auf jeden Fall
ist wirklich unglaublich aber wir gehen
jetzt ins TERAs das ist ein Casino Hotel
so wie die allermeisten Hotels hier
indem ein ganz neues Restaurant
aufgemacht hat deshalb machen wir uns
mal auf die Suche BR man muss schon
sagen Las Vegas at night ist einfach
noch mal noch eine Ecke schöner als das
ist schon wie so ein riesiges
fantasiaaland hier
einfach
es läuft wieder genau wie beim letzten
der man so der wenn der was sagt so dann
muss es
passieren was soll man dazu sagen ich
GLB das ist mit ein der schönsten
Restaurants den ich jemals
war
was für ein wunderschönes Restaurant wir
haben wirklich eine ganz ganz nette
Einführung bekommen von unserem
kellerner haben es aber ganz simpel
gehalten und das einfach vielleicht wir
wissen noch nicht ob es klappt auf
gordens Nacken ein paar Austern bestellt
und ein paar P scallops also
Jakobsmuscheln wir filmen auch alles mit
iPhone wir haben gar keine Kamera
mitgenommen das ist alles ein Zufall
dieses Video es ist wirklich das ist Las
Vegas Baby wir sind heute morgen
losgegangen haben uns ein Kaffee geholt
wir wollten uns einen Kaffee holen und
alles andere ist danach
passiert oh
wow
amazing einmal Westküste einmal Ostküste
die sind aus Washington DC also das ist
doch ein Service hier ne kriegt man
wirklich eine wunderschöne Präsentation
mit unseren ausern und American style
das hier gemacht das heißt wir kriegen
die quasi einmal mit einer Salza und
einmal mit einer vinigret das kN man ja
auch aus Frankreich ein bisschen Zitrone
probier erstmal ganz
klassisch schmecken wirklich gut W nicht
dass amerikanische Ausland so gut sind
mild irgendwie sehr sehr geil mal ein
bisschen was von dieser Sauce
drauf muss man mögen aber ich musste sie
jetzt bestellen weil wie oft kann man
schon sagen dass man von Gord rsey auf
Ausland eingeladen wurde echt geil für
Ausland ne der einzige Grund weshalb ich
hier nicht gerade so komplett ausraste
ist dass ich halt Kran jetl bin und das
alles gar nicht verstehe was hier
passiertow3
43 für 3 Jakobsmuscheln und zwei Stücke
forkelly schauen wir mal ob die auch auf
der Innenseite schön glasig sind sehen
sehr geil aus das ist wirklich ein Bild
für die Götter und die werde ich jetzt
probieren diese Jakobs mususchel mit
dieser J die auf dem Teller ist das ist
das bestessere Surf in turf ich habe
jetzt bei vielen Gord Ramy Spots
gegessen einmal waren wir enttäuscht
dieses Qualitätsmanagement was der in
seinen Leben leistet oder das geleistet
wird weil er macht sie sicherlich nicht
selbst ist unglaublich weil das ist eine
riesige Marke die der Typ hat und diese
Qualität Standort übergreifend in so
vielen Ländern verfügbar ist ist einfach
beeindruckend also ganz krank diesen
Gang würde ich mir fünf mal bestellen
300 ärmer aber es ist unglaublich
lecker
wow wir gehen rein wow Leute das hier
ist das signature Gord R Dessert
[Musik]
Schokokuchen diese Karamellnote dieses
nicht so ganz super süße Eis der
fluffige Kuchen das ist wirklich richtig
krank lecker Restaurant was auf jeden
Fall wert ist besucht zu werden auch
wenn man nicht von Gorden Ramy
eingeladen wird just one more time for
the car we don't have to pay
das ist so eine kranke Welt gerade diger
wir R uns ein bisschen aus ma einen
kleinenp und dann gehen wir heute Abend
essen würde ich sagen
bei
kitchen Freunde es ist Zeit bei Gord RAM
zu
[Applaus]
essen K Eiswürfel und gebrandete also
wirklich gebrandete zitronenschade das
ist so
krank ich hoffe dass wir nicht bezahlen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
müssen mittlerweile habe ich Routine
trink mein Cocktail
dabei
CRA mein Hauptgang alleine
84 ohne S ohne s Bestellung ist auf
jeden Fall raus ich Wste dasington
bestellen weil ich habe in London gehabt
und es sieht ein bisschen anders
ausassiker ich bin sehr gespannt wie das
hier ankommt weil das geht mir nicht aus
dem Kopf seitdem ich das
hatte glaube die EXP nicht ganz sein
wird weil man merkt schon dass es eher
so auf Volumen gemacht und so das ganze
ist nicht so obwohl es teurer ist ist
nicht so fein dining wie in London aber
sehr sehr geil aus garpun ist ein Point
auf jeden Fall beim mignor da
drin diese Geschichte kann niemand
erzählen wow es wir butterzart die
Qualität stimmt einfach wei ich sagen
würde das GLB ich so kulinar
das Restaurant von heute
Mittag kitchen so noch geiler
war
394 € normalerweise wir haben keine
Vorspeisen keine Nachspeisen bestellt
aber ja good
kitchenord ja fre so geht ein besonderer
Tag zu Ende den ich lange nicht
vergessen werde vielen vielen Dank an
RAM ich sag das ob das jemals sehen
würde aber hier vorne hat alles begonnen
wo jetzt gerade ein bisschen Regen ist
einfach ein geiler Tag danke fürs
zusehen wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal
wieder so ein Video gibt erstmal nicht
mehr aber hat Spaß gemacht CIA
ciao